Matthew Stafford turnt Lions quarterback
it's been the subject of rumors and
reports of a possible trade and the
lines have done everything they could to
knock it down it bubbled up again on
Friday Mike Silverman of own Network
said that there are coaches and GM's
at the Scouting Combine that believe
this all started because Stafford wants
out and that prompted the most
definitive statement yet from Stafford's
camp his wife Kelly who who suggested a
few weeks ago that if the lines are done
with Matthew Stafford they'd like to
play for the Lions she came out and said
he doesn't want out he wants to stay
with the Lions Tom Condon his agent told
silver that Matthew Stafford doesn't
want out so it's been put to rest so
with the news that Matthew Stafford
wants to stay in Detroit it's
fill-in-the-blanks time Chris Matt
Stafford has blank seasons left as a
member of the Detroit Lions well you
know if I want to say one seasons left
or I want to see I don't even know how
to fill in the blank here with this I
want to say pending on how this season
goes I mean that's really where I want
to want to like really answer it I think
Matt's average career in Detroit and a
lot is gonna be dictated about how this
season goes I do yes I think that if
they go to the playoffs he saves Matt
Patricia Bob Quinn's job does that then
Matt's average is gonna be there for a
few more years after that I think that
if they don't go to the playoffs and
it's you know a seven and nine type year
that it's gonna be all over in Detroit
I think Matt Stafford will be on another
team and Matt Patricia and Bob Quinn
will be gone as well so you know I don't
know you know I think it depends on how
the season goes I really do I think this
will dictate how many more years he is
left in Detroit I agree with you
completely because if they clean out
everything after this season it could be
that a new coach a new GM decides we
need a new direction we need to go in a
different way we need to find a new
quarterback we've had this guy since
2009 it hasn't gotten us to where we
want to be they haven't won a playoff
game since 1991 for crying out loud I
agree with you at least one more season
is what I would say and it's to be
determined and we can't get away from
the chatter about them taking to Otunga
by llola with the third overall pick
when Vegas
makes the lines in the Dolphins the co
favorites from a betting perspective to
take to a tongue of Aloha that makes me
think they know something and and it
would seem very odd if they do it and it
wouldn't be a move aimed at winning now
but man if they do that it is one more
season for Matthew Stafford yeah I mean
if they do that I would think maybe they
trying to trade to Matt Stafford at some
point you know after the draft if they
did that I would just be shot I just
can't imagine again I know we've
discussed this you and I before but in
Bob Quinn Matt patrícia make-or-break
year bring in a guy like to uh we don't
know if he can play year one he's a
little risk there and yeah it just I
think would throw the organization and
disarray right now they need something
you know stable and Matt Stafford is the
best player on their team and I think if
they're going to win they need him to be
there to help them out so I would just
be shocked if they went the quarterback
route this year
okay the Bears called some Patriots all
reportedly have interest in the red
rifle Andy Dalton the Bengals
quarterback since he was drafted in
round two back in 2011 if I was one of
those general managers I'd give up blank
to acquire El Diablo well I yeah I like
that I would say you know and I would
expect all three of these teams to be in
this conversation for Andy Dalton you
know I would say a third rounder maybe a
second okay now I say third rounder okay
and I look at it like this like Jimmy
Garoppolo right the San Francisco 49ers
traded traded to get him for a
second-round pick I think Andy Dalton
has more
you know pelts on his horse than a Jimmy
Garoppolo did at that point so he's
worth the second round pick for sure but
the other thing that plays into this
right Mike is we expect we know they're
gonna take Joe borough as of right now
that's what we think so they lose
leverage because of that a little bit so
and I know they're not just gonna sell
them for free so I would say I would
offer a third at first kind of get a
gauge for the market and then maybe if
you got to go to a second round like
your New England and you're picking
towards the second in the round then
maybe maybe I would do that but that I
would be thinking third at first see
they don't need to sell this idea that
maybe we'll keep Andy Dalton when you've
gotten multiple people at the auction
when you've got two or three teams that
want him and they know there's another
alternative they can bid up the price
even if everyone knows that Bengals are
done with him
the wild-card in this is the seventeen
point five million dollar salary he's
due to make this year in the final year
of his contract right because you'd like
to extend his deal well what's he worth
you're trading in a very affordable
final year of his contract you don't
want him to walk out the door after one
year but what does he really want and
does he want to go I think that's part
of it too
which team does he want to go to because
you can't trade into a team he doesn't
want to be with you need your starting
quarterback to be all-in so I think that
a third rounder makes sense I wish more
teams did draft picks based upon what
the guy does when he gets there and I
know that pushes the compensation into
the next year but I think it would be
more fair to tie the compensation to
what he does if he takes you to the
playoffs you get a higher pick if he
wins a playoff game you get a higher
pick I mean that kind of thing but I'd
say third rounder makes sense we all
think that the Patriots didn't get
enough for Garoppolo with a second
rounder
but I think a third rounder is fair for
Andy Dalton given where he is right now
in his career and given that you're
gonna have to solve this contract issue
right out of the gates Chris yeah yeah I
hear that all the way and you know Andy
Dalton is again another one of these
pieces what what plays into all this
again what we're talking about is Brady
Phillip Rivers that whole conversation
where do they go in this whole thing
that's gonna dictate Andy Dalton's
future as well but I'm not shocked to
hear any of those teams and you know the
Bears of the one team you know I always
thought from the get-go that made sense
there but you know I get the Colts and
Patriots have an interest as well and I
think it makes sense for the Bengals to
get in on this now and try to line
something up before free agency even
starts you know you can work out a trade
that becomes official when the new
league year opens on March 18 because
you don't want Andy Dalton to be one of
the quarterbacks who's standing around
when the music stops after free agency
and the money's been paid and and
there's no seat for him now's the time
to get maximum trade value for Andy
Dalton because you get him to one of
these teams that is trying to figure out
what the hell they're gonna do next year
and they want to move the uncertainty
this is a way to do it all right
according to the South Florida Sun
Sentinel Washington is told to a talk
about low at the Scouting Combine that
he could be draft
to compete with Dwayne Hoskins a report
from a Miami newspaper about a prospect
the Dolphins would have to trade up to
acquire is ice what do you what are we
asking there would have to trade up to
it what are we asking there the point is
the point is there's a Miami newspaper
right over the Dolphins is that's
reporting that basically on a
quarterback that the Dolphins would have
to trade up to get so is it is it bogus
is it crap it's a smokescreen helling
to me okay I just wasn't sure how we
were what kind of answer we were looking
for there but yeah I mean I say this
talked anything other than you puking in
the trash can is an improvement over
last week you can say whatever you want
okay all right that's good and I won't
be puking here so I should be good but I
to me right now I just feel like
Washington's laying like smoke screens
out right now they're in the prime
position the number two pick in the
draft we know there's a chase young
market of course we know there's teams
that are hungry and thirsty for
quarterback play too and I feel like
from the get-go here and again I have no
inside knowledge here but it just seems
to me like they're playing the oh we're
not sure about Dwayne Haskins and we
might take a quarterback here to drive
up that asking price in case somebody
wants to do business there and get into
that number 2 spot so I don't know I
don't know if I'm sitting here
necessarily buying it from the
Washington standpoint that you know I
heard you know they might they told to
it we might bring you into drafty or
compete with Dwayne Haskins I think they
probably told two of that knowing to was
gonna tell some other people that and it
continues to stir the pot here in this
whole conversation so I'm not quite
buying it yet and I don't know I just
have a hard time with Dwayne Haskins so
they'd seen enough to abandon ship and
move on and then you're gonna waste
another top 15 pick on a quarterback I
don't want to say a waste but you know
use another top 15 pick on a quarterback
I have a hard time I guess digesting
that right now here's the other thing to
keep in mind as well and and and I think
it's an important aspect of what
Washington is gonna do with that pick in
order to engage in the most informed and
viable trade discussions you need to
know everything you can about the
player cuz you're not trading the pic
you're trading the player so you do the
full workup on tour so if Miami calls
you can counter everything they would
say and you can say here's why we think
he's worth X right because we talked to
the kid we love the kid right invested
the 15 overall pick last year and we'd
take him and maybe we will take him
maybe you know that's the whole idea you
want to make the Dolphins think yes it
the the Washington franchise may take
him and the Washington franchise needs
to know all about him
so they can hold firm and trade
discussions to maximize their return
this is their chance to turn the tables
on some unsuspecting team the way they
got screwed
eight years ago in the rg3 trade they
moved from six to two and gave up way
too much for rg3 now they get a chance
to get somebody to give up way too much
potentially for two oh alright next one
the Cowboys reportedly planning to use
the exclusive franchise tender on dak
Prescott the exclusive tag for Prescott
means blank for his future with the
Cowboys nothing it means nothing to me
it doesn't matter franchise stag
exclusive tag I don't think it really
changes my thought I mean you probably
have a smart and smarter answer than me
here but you know nonetheless you know
that there got to get a long-term deal
done and an exclusive tag franchise tag
it doesn't matter dak ain't gonna be
there no matter what kind of tag you got
on him until that tag is torn off and
you've bought in him now okay and it
says he's no more on the shelves at the
retail store and he's your property you
could tag them with ever helm phrase you
want oh he ain't coming around until he
gets a long-term deal you know I really
debated giving you a hard time for
saying bought and I know when I said it
I was like wow that was full stupid
right there but I was too deep in my
thought I couldn't I couldn't backtrack
after that here's the problem if they
use the franchise tag exclusive level on
dak Prescott they have bought in
themselves at least 31 million dollars
under the tag this year a 20% raise next
year why not go year to year
that's what dak Prescott is eventually
going to realize and the higher the tag
value the greater the second year is and
the
the third year is year three it's a 44%
raise over year - you're talking about
astronomical numbers if that Prescott
goes year to year and I've been waiting
for one of these shortlist franchise
quarterbacks to do what Kirk Cousins did
with Washington a few years ago just
play year-to-year under the tag now the
other question becomes if DAC is tagged
will he withhold services I mean maybe
he signs it right away and shows up and
says I'm gonna have a great year and
you're gonna tag me next year I'm gonna
have another great year and then you're
gonna be stuck and I'm gonna become a
free agent after two more seasons six
years total in the NFL and I'm gonna be
able to hit the market unfettered and go
wherever I want so I think it actually
if they use the exclusive tag I think it
actually makes it less likely he's there
over the long haul than if they would
use the non-exclusive well the one thing
I'll say - what you're saying I mean I
hear what you're saying from the
business standpoint and if there's a you
know a quarterback a big soldier who
could you know you know bet on himself
to stay healthy and do that it would be
dak Prescott I mean you know again other
than Cam Newton you're not gonna find a
whole quarter a whole lot of
quarterbacks that physically look the
way dak Prescott does I mean he is a
he's man I mean he really is he's thick
strong as hell in shape all of that plus
we know with the way the rules are for
the quarterbacks right now a gamble like
that is less dangerous than it was in
the 80s and 90s to protect the
quarterback so you could do that
certainly but it's still risky business
and I just don't recommend it and you
know with the exclusive French tag - if
I'm dak Prescott like that's what I
would do something like you said Mike
maybe sign it I would show up start and
learning the offense doing things like
that oh hey you're going on the field
sorry guys I got the exclusive tag I got
to go home I'm exclusively not going on
that field to give you reps that's not
happening I would just play a hard ball
like that I would learn the offense but
as soon as it went to like oh we're
gonna go in the field oh it's time for
OTAs I'll be exclusively in my Ferrari
in the parking lot okay I mean that's
what I would do to them
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports